es ist immer so schön dass in die Medien
quasi erklärt wird ja die Speicher sind
zu 94% voll das klingt super das Problem
dabei was ich aber leider sehe ist ich
werde zum Beispiel gastechnisch Liebe in
Lettland die haben nur 53% in die
Speicher drin die Frage ist ganz einfach
wie lange reichen die Speicher bei den
letzten reichen die 110% des Jahres das
heißt selbst wenn die kein Gas mehr
bekommen sein die ein yourself bei uns
ist es so wenn man die Tabelle naisch
hat noch die 94% drei Spalten rechts
daneben steht 25,6 Prozent und das ist
es was von unserem Jahresbedarf
tatsächlich in die Speicher verfügbar
ist und wenn man dann noch weiß dass man
von Oktober bis April rund 75% unserer
Speicher eigentlich Verb also unseres
Jahresverbrauchs verbrauchen dann haben
wir momentan ein Drittel von dem Gas ist
man benötigen das ist die große Frage ob
es reicht das was man momentan
importieren im das muss man exportieren
mehr leiten ja viel Gas einfach nur
durch und das neueste ist ja jetzt dass
uns zu Gast ist wir mit Steuermillionen
ja Milliarden kaufen gar nicht gehört
oder mir Verkaufsrecht oder sowas haben
und wenn natürlich das Gas ausgeht dann
haben wir im Gegensatz zur Meinung
mancher Politiker natürlicher
Stromproblem weil wir noch nie so viel
Strom
so viel Gas verstromt haben wie zuvor
weil man eben durch die Energiewende von
Kohlekraftwerke auf Gaskraftwerke
umgestellt haben und dann damit ist es
natürlich nicht verwunderlich dass man
im September 2015 ein Gigawatt Gasstrom
hatten und die letzten September hat man
bis zu 10 Gigawatt
wenn der Blackout dann kommen sollte was
passiert da genau
also wenn tatsächlich man musste erst
mit definieren Blackout ich nehme hier
die Definition des Bundesamt für
Bevölkerungsschutz und Katastrophenhilfe
der geht dann mindestens drei Tage lang
und betrifft mehrere Bundesländer alles
andere ist es sogenannte wir nennen das
braunout großflächiger Stromausfall und
wenn es tatsächlich zu einem Blackout
kommt dann ist natürlich klar Steinzeit
einfach mal vor Sie sitzen daheim was
geht die noch in ihrem Haus ohne Strom
was geht da es geht nichts mehr
EC-Automat mehr gehen um Bargeld
erzielen es geht kein Supermarkt mehr es
geht die Tankstelle nicht mehr hat der
Batterie man hat Kerzen haben wir doch
jetzt alles zu Hause ja wenn man die
daheim hat ist die schon mal gute Anfang
es geht die Wasserversorgung nicht mehr
das ist zum Beispiel was was die meisten
leider vergessen gerade die wir mit
diesen Sprudler daheim haben die haben
ja keine Wasserflaschen mehr gelagert
und die meisten haben die meisten
wasserversagen haben für so 24 Stunden
bringen die Wasser und dann noch was ist
und es gibt ein kleine Nebeneffekt davon
dass natürlich ja die Toilettenspülung
da nicht mehr funktioniert und das ist
natürlich ein sehr unangenehmes Problem
weil wie wird man eigentlich Blackout
Experte das habe ich mich heute schon
den ganzen Tag gefragt auch wenn ich ihn
jetzt höre auch mit der Toilette wie
kommt man auf diesen Beruf
wie kommt man auf diesen Beruf
tatsächlicherweise habe ich vor vier
Jahren wieder das Buch Blackout gelesen
von Mark Elsberg mein Lieblingsbuch muss
ich sagen und dann hat mich einfach mal
interessiert wer ein Blackout in
Deutschland möglich und ich bin gelernte
Energieanlagen Elektroniker war aber
jetzt lang in der anderen Branche tätig
und dann habe ich mir einfach unser
Stromnetz mal angeschaut ich war
entsetzt wie sich unser Stromnetz in den
letzten 20 Jahre verändert hat wie viele
eingriffsmaßnahmen jetzt notwendig kann
wir haben früher im Jahr drei bis sechs
Mal eingegriffen letztes Jahr 8600 mal
und dieses Jahr haben wir letzte Woche
die 10.000 der Grenze überschritten von
Eingriffen sogenannten
redispechmaßnahmen um die Stromnetz noch
stabil zu halten und es zeigt einfach
wie instabil dass unser Stromnetz ist
und jetzt kommt natürlich die Gaskrise
noch ein Top und wer wird dann helfen
also wenn der Blackout dann da ist
dieses Horror Szenario die Bundeswehr
wie funktioniert das dann
also ich nenne es mal ich sag's mal mit
den Worten von der Hauptfrau von
Vorarlberg die einfach gesagt hat es
braucht keine erwarten dass dort jemand
der Butterbrot schmiert und ist auf dem
Silbertablett er nimmt ich selbst bin
Helfer Katastrophenschützer beim THW
also ehrenamtlich und ich muss sagen wir
werden tun was wir können aber wir sind
viel zu denke ich müsste wir haben
80.000 THW da haben aber schon 16.000
Kinder mit drin und das heißt jeder von
uns müsste für 1000 Leute alleine ihr
Gartenparty schmeißen was zum Essen
organisieren das ist also in keinster
Weise möglich und wir haben im Alltag
gesehen da waren 40.000 ja nur betroffen
und da waren eigentlich die Katastrophen
die ganzen Helfer schon eigentlich am
Limit und jetzt stellen wir uns mal vor
es wären 4 Millionen betroffen oder
vielleicht sogar 40 Millionen aber ich
meine es ist daran sie haben sie zu
Recht gesagt 1 Szenario und sie es
klingt in ihren Worten jetzt so also ja
irgendwann in diesem Herbst Winter kommt
halt der Blackout 3 bis 5 Tage schaut
also dies und jenes macht wir reden noch
nach wie vor und diese Hoffnung möchte
ich mir heute abend nicht rauben lassen
auch von ihnen nicht wir leben doch nach
wie vor in einem Szenario und dem das
sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich ist oder
leben wir nicht von Promille oder reden
wir von zehn Prozent wir reden von weit
weit mehr das sagen Sie jetzt nee das
soll nicht das sagt sogar die
Bundesnetzagentur nämlich habe konnte er
vor kurzem diese gastszenarien
vorgestellt haben sie mitbekommen und
ohne russisches Gas fahren von diese
18-Jährigen dann quasi in einer
gasmangel Lage wo es für mich die
Katastrophe ist weil man in dem Moment
müsste man dann einfach den Strom die
Gaskraftwerke reduzieren und es wird
vielleicht dann also wenn man zu wenig
Strom dann im Netz haben kommt
vielleicht die Schweizer Modell die
Schweizer Regierung hat bereits im Juni
angekündigt ein Modell ist zum Beispiel
du hast vier Stunden Strom du hast vier
Stunden keinen Strom du hast vier
Stunden Strom vier Stunden keinen Strom
und sowas in die Richtung könnte dann in
Deutschland auch kommen wenn wirklich
der Strom zu wenig wird und momentan
sieht der dann auch aus ich hoffe es
ändert sich noch
das ist halt dann wie gesagt bei jedem
wieder anfahren wenn das alles wieder
anspringt dann läuft jeder Kühlschrank
los jede Maschine läuft los jede
Elektroheizung läuft los jede Wärmepumpe
und das ist die sogenannte stromgear das
ist das was jeden Netzwerktechniker die
schweißstirn auf die
Schweißperlen auf die Stirn bringt
einfach aus dem Grund weil man dort das
vier bis zum zehnfachmann Strom brauchen
und der glühende Leitungen dann fällt
irgendwann die Sicherung
sehr ungläubig bei der Szenario
Beschreibung nein ich verlasse mich da
auf die Experten und ich bin Experte für
Sicherheitspolitik und als solcher hier
eingeladen damit beschäftigen mich im
Augenblick ganz andere Fragen das muss
ich wirklich sagen sie haben mich
vorgestellt hier mit der These mit Putin
ist nicht zu spaßen ich habe genau das
Gegenteil gesagt von Putin sollten wir
uns nicht einschüchtern lassen und ich
habe die Sorge dass die Verängstigung
auch bei unserer politischen Klasse
durch seine letzten Schritte also die
Annexion der Gebiete die er jetzt als
Russland erklärt die Teilmobilmachung
die nuklearen Drohungen und jetzt die
gestrigen noch zu ihrem Blog wir machen
kurz mit dem Blackout zu Ende und dann
werde ich ihr das vorstellen mit mit
Putin ist zu spaßen oder wir werden dann
noch mal darüber reden wie wir es
vorstellen werden ein Leben Gedanken
wollte ich auch noch mal kurz aufgreifen
wenn Sie gesagt haben erst seit 20
Jahren neben die Eingriffe ins Stromnetz
und Stromnetz ist ja Teil der
Infrastruktur immer mehr zu das heißt
wir reden hier offen 16 Jahren Frau
Merkel wir reden von jede Mengen großen
Koalition kleinen Koalitionen was es
überall gab in den Ländern und
daeinsvorsorge Infrastruktur ist durch
die Kernaufgabe unseres Staates müssen
wir uns also da weigere ich mich
eigentlich aber müssen wir uns an das
Bild gewöhnen dass 16 20 Jahre lang der
Staat seiner Kernaufgabe nämlich der
Daseinsvorsorge nicht nachgekommen ist
da hätte ja fast sämtliche
Legitimationen verspielt
verliert eine Frage habe ich auch an sie
was macht das eigentlich psychologisch
mit uns allen diese Krisen und ich würde
nur kurz ergänzen weil weil sie fuhren
Lettland angesprochen haben ich war
nämlich zufällig gerade in Lettland und
es ist in der Tat dort überhaupt gar
kein Thema das ganze auch ich war dann
auch in Litauen es ist kein Thema die
die Energie Frage auch in anderen
Ländern ist es wird überhaupt nicht
darüber diskutiert
also dann wenn das so wäre dann hätte
man wirklich in Deutschland über Jahre
hinweg geschlammt und dann wäre also der
Staat Kernaufgaben nicht nachgekommen
und das ist wirklich ein Problem und das
hat dann natürlich auch auch und gerade
diese psychologischen Auswirkungen denn
es ist ja manchmal nicht nur dass die
die Krise selbst und die Angst vor der
Krise die die vielleicht kommt die Krise
ja gar nicht also es gibt noch eine
Chance dass sie nicht kommen würde ich
sagen aber aber auch die Angst macht
etwas mit den Menschen natürlich und die
Menschen die auch gerade zweieinhalb
Jahre corona-krise auch mit mit Regeln
psychischen Auswirkungen schweren
mentalen Auswirkungen erlebt haben auch
gerade auch für die junge Generation
aber auch andere und jetzt dieses jetzt
doch da drauf ich glaube das ist
wirklich etwas was sich so für einen wie
soll man das sagen so ein mentales
Gesamtbild einer Bevölkerung glaube ich
keine gute Entwicklung ist und darum
mache ich mir Sorgen ja man sieht es ja
auch schon an den Zahlen das nehmen ja
auch schon Suizide zu vor allem in der
corona-krise haben die zugenommen aber
auch Depression ich frage mich oft was
es mit den heranwachsen macht mit der
Generation die jetzt eigentlich
heranwächst
ja da beobachten wir genau das was Sie
gesagt haben und und ich meine früher
gab es mal die no future Generation aber
die hatte eigentlich keine wirklich
Angst in diesem Sinne also die hat ja
eigentlich gar nicht erlebt das waren ja
so eine Ehre des bezog sich auf was
anderes aber heute glaube ich schon das
ist das das und das wir können das sehen
an den Zahlen wie denen
das Menschen gerade jüngere Menschen
sich grundsätzliche Sorgen darüber
machen ob sie wirklich in einer guten
Zukunft leben werden ob sie diese den
Lebensstandard den sie jetzt haben
halten werden und das muss noch nicht
bedeuten dass sie davor Angst haben dass
sie Hunger leiden werden oder richtig in
Armut rutschen sondern dass sie einfach
den Standard nicht halten können und und
Abrutschen werden über Krise Nummer eins
die wird zumindest so wahrgenommen und
da muss ich zumindest dann das Lob für
Frau thumberg wieder einkassieren Krise
Nummer eins in der Wahrnehmung
heranwachsen ist die sogenannte
Klimakatastrophe also es wächst wirklich
eine Generation heran von großteils oder
vielen verängstigen jungen Menschen die
also wirklich der Meinung sind also in
10 oder 20 Jahren geht die Erde unter
wenn wir nicht sofort aus allen fossilen
energiestoffen aussteigen und dieser
Angst vor der Klimakatastrophe ich halt
schon das Wort falsch vor der
Klimakatastrophe führt eben dazu dass
viele kein zutrauen mehr haben auch ihre
eigene Gestaltungsmöglichkeiten das
finde ich ist ganz ganz schlimm wenn
Menschen heranwachsen ohne zutrauen dass
sie in dieser Welt wirklich etwas
bewegen können
und was kann man dagegen tun ich glaube
man kann nur appellieren an die
zukunftsorte zunächst einmal es ist
nicht es ist nicht ruchlochbar es ist
nicht verboten optimistisch zu sein
kreativ zu sein Menschen können erfinden
es gibt keine eingängigen Wege es gibt
immer Alternative die Katastrophe wurde
schon 100 mal ausgerufen sie hat noch
nie also der Weltuntergang noch nie
stattgefunden die Apokalypse lässt auf
sich warten also ich glaube Panik ist
kein guter Ratgeber weder beim Blackout
noch bei Frau Thunberg